as we told you just a moment ago we are
just two business days away from the
prospect of another government shutdown
the clock runs out at midnight Thursday
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel tells us tonight from Capitol
Hill neither Democrats nor Republicans
seem to have the will to make any kind
of long-term commitments the only reason
we do not have a full budget agreement
is because Democrats continue to hold
funding for our government hostage on an
unrelated issue so lawmakers are voting
this week on a fifth continuing
resolution to fund the government from
Thursday night to March 23rd it would
also extend funding for a number of
Medicare pieces and critical public
health programs including community
health centers it's time now to focus on
meeting these essential services
particularly health care and health care
services that are a lifeline Murphy to
win over defense hawks and conservatives
this extension includes increased
funding for the military through the end
of the fiscal year that brought the
conservative house freedom caucus on
board but Democratic leader Chuck
Schumer has declared the house plan dead
on arrival in the Senate holding out for
more domestic spending today the House
Armed Services Committee got an earful
from the Secretary of Defense warning
frequent continuing resolutions and the
existing budget caps are causing the
American military advantage to shrink
the combination of rapidly changing
technology the negative impact on
military readiness resulting from the
longest continuous stretch of combat in
our nation's history and insufficient
funding have created an overstretched
and under-resourced military that may
help the top four congressional leaders
with efforts to get a new long term
funding agreement with more money for
the military and domestic priorities
nearly three hundred billion dollars
more for the next two years which could
get tucked into a short-term extension
I'm optimistic that very soon we'll be
able to reach an agreement I've
discussed some of the outlines with my
caucus that I think
we are very happy with and hopefully the
Republicans are and then we can get
something really good done a budget caps
agreement would make most feel better
about voting for a fifth temporary
government funding extension but more
spending could create new headaches for
GOP leaders when it comes time to raise
the debt ceiling in the coming weeks
Jenna's and it all plays out against the
backdrop of the midterms as well my
Camano on Capitol Hill thank you